the clippers and represent the team from
southern california oh you won't say
that
i'm not talking about i'm not talking
about there is there a point at which
you said okay i'm now i'm going to say
their name
if they win a playoff game so you're not
going to say the word lakers for the
rest of the the rest of the season i'm
not talking about these damn losers
we but
between us between the nitwits the tnt
and the nisswitz or espn we talk about
these losers more than any people in the
world i would say we talked about them a
lot though thank you and we show them
all the time i feel like a prisoner in
alcatraz being forced to watch sacred
steppers game in prime time until inside
the hey jb i feel your pain i'm not
talking about them losers anymore this
year
here are your american express teammates
coming from the clipper side of things
reggie jackson a 15 point first half for
the clips and
robert covington off of that
tai lu bench can i say something coming
through with 10 yeah some more yeah go
ahead and say something reggie said
something very interesting and man kenny
talked about it
i thought what the clippers did at the
trade deadline was spectacular
and when they get kawhi and paul george
back next year
they're going to be a handful for
anybody in the nba
true yes great yeah yeah paul george
26 games has missed 38 in those 26. you
know like 45 25 why don't you think that
what chuck said is accurate i mean i'm
saying that for years no no no no they
they when they got kawhi and paul george
they became a legitimate team yeah and
they made they say they made some great
trends they had the norman powell thing
and now you know
three games yeah powell and covered when
they get when they get their two boys
back you know what else sounded good
what
oh we're gonna get lebron or we're gonna
get carmelo who are we gonna get rusty
no no no no no no it sounded good yeah
first of all we said from the beginning
of the season
we said to lit
i almost said yeah
i said we said that from south carolina
southern california was going to stink
because they had all the mold geezers
out there except if anthony davis played
mvp level basketball he has not played
because he's been hurt and the rest of
them old geezers out there on geratol
uh and azor bean jr and bengay
azor b
you don't know what that is shaq yeah no
i do not
yeah it was long before i see her it's
the original icy hot okay
man up
let's get into a couple of breakdown
tapes i'll go quick i'll go quick i'll
go quickly
nobody's coming great all right but we
talk about when we i just watched the
game with john moran who's a guy who
could score in traffic here's we talk
about laker problems one of the laker
problems is
these are guys who can score with space
but cannot score with in traffic or with
lack of spacing so freeze it here you
got my man cutting through getting
bumped twice you got monk on the ball
he uh dwight howard
there's another guy not really a space
scorer so he needs space to score he's
not really scoring traffic so as the
play runs there's so much
emphasis and frees it one more time so
you got
one two three four five guys in the
paint
one two three four guys who really
are not able to score or get seen so you
if you don't score in traffic you can't
find the guys out here hands be active
hands active ready again on the second
time
not really guys who can score in traffic
you don't get back or we could score on
transition and now you're not getting
back in transition you get a three
knocked in your head and for me
they just with anthony davis he scores
in traffic when he scores in traffic now
the shooters are open yeah but when
you're not scoring in traffic check can
i ask you a question you're not good
yeah but he's got he's got some tape
okay go ahead first i got some tape my
favorite movie is rudy rolly tape let me
tell you why okay
because rudy we played with a bunch of
superstars but rudy just came out and
played hard rarely talked about look i'm
just going to come out and do my job
right there open three boom i'm gonna
get this crowd in the game and see all i
did was superstar though no lebron in
the game this is when lebron leads but
right here you know you got all these
superstars in the game they you know
they are who they are but i'm gonna play
hard i'm gonna give maximum effort i'm
gonna keep everybody involved i'm gonna
get this crowd back in the game and like
dr o'neill said we will win this game
because of rudy aka also but shaq the
one thing about that one lebron the
highlights i was trying to emphasize is
when lebron leaves the game but secondly
the game isn't played in fast breaks in
the fourth quarter
they can't score in a half court set or
guard anybody or guard anyone so what
happens when your heart gets down to the
stretch with you you play hard you lose
by six like they did the other ask y'all
my question what's that does brony start
or come off the bench if he gets on this
team this year who ronnie
come on we need y'all to see hurricane
[Laughter]
clippers 66-63
the clipper bench outscoring the lakers
34 to 11. come on marie simmer brown
that's some old games out there girl
simmer down does brownies start now